I wonder who might be without my fame,
who would I be if I said things that
people didn't want to hear or if I
defied their expectations of me,
what if I showed up to the party without
my Mardi gras back mask and refuse to
flash my breasts for him full of beans?
I'll give you a moment to wipe that
image out of your mind right when I was
about 28,
after a decade as a professional
comedian,
I realized one night in La with the
purpose of my life had always been to
free people from concern just like my
dad,
and when I realized this,
I dubbed my new devotion,
the Church of freedom from concern,
the Church of FFC.
Thank you.
I dedicated myself to that ministry.
What's yours?
How will you serve the world?
What do they need that your talent can
provide?
That's all you have to figure it out.
As someone who's done what you're about
to go and do,
I can tell you from experience,
the effect you have on others is the
most valuable currency.
There is.
Everything you gain in life will rot and
fall apart and all that will be left of
you is what was in your heart mind
choosing to free people from concern me
to the top of a mountain.
Look where I am.
Look what I get to everywhere I go,
I'm going to get emotional because when
I tapped into this,
it really is extraordinary to me.
I did something that made people present
their best selves to meet wherever I go.
I am at the top of the mountain and I
was and I the only.
The only one I hadn't freed was myself,
and that's when my search for identity
deep.
You can join the game.
Fight the wars,
play with form all you want,
but to find real peace,
you have to let the armor,
your need for acceptance can make you
invisible in this world.
Don't let anything stand in the way of
the light that shines through this form.
Now,
fear is going to be a player in your
life,
but you get to decide how much you can
spend your whole life imagining ghosts,
worrying about the pathway to the
future,
but all there will ever be is what's
happening here and the decisions we make
in this moment which are based in either
love or fear.
So many of us choose our path out of
fear disguised as practicality.
What we really want seems impossibly out
of reach and ridiculous to expect,
so we never dared asked the universe for
it.
I'm saying I'm the proof that you can
ask the universe for it.
I learned many great lessons from my not
the least of which was that you can fail
at what you don't want,
so you might as well take a chance on
doing what you love.
The thank you.